la sphère ppda n'a pas fini de faire
parler patrick poivre d'arvor patrick
poivre d'arvor retour sur la sphère ppda
alors que le journaliste avait été
accusé de viol le 15 février 2021 par
florence porcel la plainte avait été
classée sans suite faute de preuves rien
ne permet de confirmer les dires de l'un
ou de l'autre autant depuis d'autres
femmes ont fait part de leurs
témoignages
elles sont 23 à dénoncer les agissements
de patrick poivre d'arvor lorsqu'il
était présentateur sur tf1 que les
témoignages se recoupent les histoires
se ressemblent tellement qu'on pourrait
parfois les superposer selon france info
aujourd'hui c'est florence porcel qui
annonce déposer à nouveau plainte
toujours pour viol mais à des
constitutions de partie civile le juge
d'instruction est donc amené à consulter
l'intégralité du dossier et à entendre
les autres fans qui ont porté plainte
depuis l' enquête pourrait donc être
relancé certains dirigeants de l'époque
pourraient être entendus alors nouvelle
plainte et révélations contre ppda la
sphère prend tel un tournant
ce que des mois c'est valérie bénaïm
avec qui me qui me parle d'autre chose
vous êtes très dissipé ce serait mais je
vous aime bien quand même les chéris
merci meriem palombes à directrice de la
france et du magazine public et et
roland perez avocat d'être avec nous on
va parler dans un instant et on à
l'affiché avec eric zemmour k.sign le
magazine closer vous allez voir pourquoi
dans un instant c'est incroyable un
voilà vous êtes public mais ce que le
public sait très bien voilà ray
d'ailleurs c'est quoi une de public ne
manque jamais de
toujours
légion var juste revenir sur la sphère
ppda
l'enquète mediapart elle a révélé quoi
mais rien à ce qu'elle a révélé c'est
que déjà d'une la première chose c'est
que les représentants du personnel ont
convoqué la direction français selon
interpellé la direction de tf1 pour
savoir s'il allait communiquer suite à
l'article de libération des journalistes
de tf1 à l'époque on aurait été agressée
sexuellement ou violée par ppda donc
déjà il ya ça ils ont demandé si nacre
une enquête interne avait été dépêchée
par par tf1 et surtout ils se sont
étonnés que ppda a eu trente minutes
antennes dans une émission de tf1 savoir
enfin deux du groupe tf1 sur tmc le
quotidien et qu'on n'avait jamais donné
la parole aux plaignantes dont qui se
sont un peu offusqué de ça et là dessus
la la la direction de tf1 leur a
confirmé qu'à sept à huit étaient en
préparation où rien ne serait censurée
de cette histoire d'accord alors eu
aujourd'hui il ya des miens il ya des
nouveautés puisque c'est vrai que on
voit que laurence pourcel a déposé une
nouvelle plainte pour viol aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on a droit de porter plainte
deux fois oui absolument en fait la
plainte simple c'est la plainte un peu
classique que tout un chacun peut
déposer et quand la plainte simple
n'aboutit pas ou si on n'a pas de
nouvelles finalement de du procureur
auprès duquel on a déposé plainte ou de
la police eh bien on peut déposer
plainte avec constitution de partie
civile ça veut dire que là forcément un
magistrat instructeur va être désigné et
que de nouveaux éléments vont être
portés à sa connaissance et là une
enquête va être diligentée des gens vont
être auditionnés des confrontations vont
pouvoir se faire donc oui c'est un lot
je disais là vous disiez est ce que
c'est un nouveau tournant oui c'est un
tournant fondamental que ppda
aujourd'hui la
sicile si les éléments sont caractérisés
les aliments de viol sont caractérisées
dans la mesure où les cdc d'affaires ne
sont pas prescrites en tout cas celle
qui viendra dans les mains du juge n'est
pas prescrite il est prévu dans le code
pénal en cas de viol une peine maximale
de 15 ans de prison gilles alors c'était
la grande question les seuls faits
éventuellement non prescrits ce sont les
faits que florence porcel décrit comme
un viol subi en 2009 en 2009 la
prescription c'était dix ans donc
jusqu'en 2019 voyez mais en 2010 cette
loi qui est passé à 20 ans et ça entre
dedans donc ces faits ne seraient pas
prescrits ça veut dire que le juge
d'instruction il va reprendre tout le
dossier il instruit que cette affaire
met pas hors de chine et tout le monde
peut-être de nouvelles victimes et il
repart à zéro il tient pas compte du
fait qu'il ya pas eu de sanction
derrière ce qui va être intéressant
surtout c'est que les par exemple les
femmes qui ont parlé à visage découvert
dans libération vont également pouvoir
donner leurs témoignages et puis là du
coup on va aussi voir si la
responsabilité tef a été engagée si à
l'époque qu'ils savaient des choses qui
n'ont rien fait myriam c'est vrai que
alors on parle pas ça tf1 parce que tf1
oui mais tu es dedans mais tout le monde
dit en ce moment c'est le gros truc tout
le monde savait tout le monde savait
tout le monde savait ça veut dire quoi
satisfaire tout le monde savait vous
avez des témoignages quand on regarde un
peu le le rapport de l' enquête vous
avez des gens comme par exemple muriel
rieuse qui dit que bas à l'époque quand
elle a été violée en 2005 et a mieux
réussi et quand même direct qui était à
l'époque directrice générale adjointe
d'une filiale de tf1 qu'elle a été
agressée en 2005 et qu'à l'époque elle
en avait parlé et que les qu'était le
pdg de tf1 et el dib à l'époque qui m'a
dit ah toi aussi il a fait ça bon voilà
france apparaît assez hallucinant opus
tf1 savait que ppda recevait des jeunes
femmes dans ses bureaux pas que c'était
faux son ancienne en panne on était
quand même plus ou moins courant c'est
l'heure les assistantes ont quand même
confirmé sa dans le rapport d' enquête
on savait qu'ils qui voit là et recevez
des jeunes femmes pourront assister au
20h lui même a reconnu dans le rapport
qu'il avait eu des rapports sexuels dans
son bureau donc donc voilà est fier
pourrions pas d'accord et que et que
voilà donc du coup ça ça pose quand même
beaucoup d'interrogations et puis quand
on regarde aussi toutes les toutes les
plaignantes qui ont parlé il ya aussi
d'autres qui disent que bas il y en a
une qui s'appelle ses six petits moreau
qui dit voilà moi à l'époque même quand
elle a quand elle a été agressée en
1996 97 elle dit moi à l'époque les rh
m'avait dit oui on sait on a même pour
consigne on aurait même eu pour consigne
de ne pas de dire à l' agence d'intérim
de ne pas engager des assistantes
administratives pour que les dégâts
qu'ils soient des jolies femmes est
plutôt de favoriser les hommes ou des
femmes voilà appelant surpoids donc nous
passe à poser des interrogations guillot
dans tout le monde était au courant que
c'était un charmeur mais tout n'était
pas aux contres c'était un violeur si
l'heure est aux comptes c'est un violeur
il faut ça dansait dans ce dossier
aucune plainte qui a été déposée contre
tf1 et c'est un peu facile quand même de
taper sur un système sur une chaise en
disant voilà tout le monde savait ce qui
est dit dans le papier de mediapart
c'est un peu fourre dit voilà il ya des
gens qui étaient au courant qu'ils
avaient des comportements suspects mais
y'a personne qui a
connu sa personne qui dit voilà ppda m'a
violée je suis allé voir la direction
pour les prévenir et ils n'ont rien fait
donc c'est un peu facile et je pense que
si effectivement les faits sont avérés
une personne alors ok on va dire que
c'était une autre époque en tout cas ce
qui est vrai et ce que disent
pratiquement toutes les femmes qui ont
travaillé pour tf1 c'est qu'à l'époque
ppda ou pas et avait quand même une
ambiance assez graveleuses assez
misogyne et dans n'importe quelle
entreprise aujourd'hui se passerait sa y
aurait il un casque et notre époque
aussi pas lier une enquête c'est bien
qu'elle ait changé reprise molle à
bernard montiel vous y étiez et papenoo
bien sûr j
entends pas là bas c'est moi et mes rien
demandé
[Rires]
je suis restée une gamme 17 ans
ce qu'on disait à l'époque effectivement
que le genre tout le monde savait que
monde savait qu'il était extrêmement
lourde au que c'était un gros secteur en
revanche je peux vous l'affirmer on n'a
jamais dit qu'il avait violée qui que ce
soit il ya jamais eu de plainte à ce
moment là maintenant ce qui est
important de dire aussi c'est que les
plaignantes actuelle il faut les croire
il faut les écouter et se laisser faire
la justice une fois qu'il en soit quoi
qu'il en soit on disait que c'était un
gros lourdaud mois n'a jamais parlé de
viol
était au courant etienne mougeotte on
parlait aussi de cuissage ou voilà
souvent il y avait quand même beaucoup
de blagues potaches visiblement qui
était faite à l'épaule sont désolés il
ya eu des mains courantes est belle
quand vous dites que les directions ne
s'en sont pas mêlés c'est pas vrai parce
qu'il ya eu des affaires il ya eu des
affrontements physiques entre patrick
poivre d'arvor et des rivaux en tant que
peuvent parfois on est des femmes deux
rivaux et donc l'intervention et la
direction d'ubs mais louis rapport ça
veut dire qu'ils deviennent sang-mêlé
puisque c'était la hiérarchie donc ils
s'en sont mêlés a par moment c'est pas
vrai quand on dit qu'ils sont pas
intervenus c'est pas vrai on en fait
certains aujourd'hui les seuls éléments
sont les seuls éléments certains dont la
justice est saisie aujourd'hui c'est la
plainte d'une seule femme aujourd'hui et
cette femme s'expose à deux choses
d'abord il va falloir quelques consignes
qu'elle donne de l'argent quelles
consignes pour donner de la force à sa
plainte ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième chose attention s'il est
finalement jugée un non lieu c'est à
dire si on estime qu a pas suffisamment
d'éléments qui prouvent parce que le
viol c'est un crime donc c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement grave c'est une
pénétration sans consentement par
contrainte par surprise donc par menace
donc ça veut dire que si on n'arrive pas
à établir la véracité de ces faits qui
sont particulièrement graves elles
s'exposaient ce qu'on appelle de
libération cas le mur de planck pour
elles elles s'exposent et exposent
son ancien employeur il ya aussi toutes
les questions de harcèlement sexuel sans
aller sur des histoires d'agressions ou
de viols canton du travail dans un
contexte misogyne ou on se perd mais
voilà de faire des blagues sur physique
afin de flatter sur le physique des
journalistes lors de conférences et de
rédaction ça reste tu harcèlement si
mais c'est prescrit valérie tétreault
perez puisqu'il ya une nouvelle donc à
une nouvelle plainte avec constitution
de partie civile il ya des nouveaux
éléments puisque ce papier de libération
avec ses 7 témoignage à visage découvert
et est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que c'est cette témoignages pourront
être versés aux deux journées alors cet
hiver la plainte de l'amiante actuelle
en fait on on ne m'a pas écouté que la
plaignante le juge d'instruction
s'autorisera également dans le cadre de
cette enquête à écouter les autres
plaignantes pour savoir s'il y avait un
procès ce qui avait été mis en place un
process de séduction qui serait
exactement le même parle parfois
d'emprise de choses comme ça donc ils
veulent voir si effectivement cette
personne dise exactement la même chose
restrictions au point qu'on peut les
entendre et le verso voilà elle soit il
n'y aura pas de on n'ouvrira pas de
plainte pour ces personnes là puisque je
sais pas a priori prescrits mais en tout
cas on peut les écouter oui jean michel
oui il ya une quinzaine d'années j'ai ya
une quinzaine d'années comme vous le
savez j'étais au figaro jeudi chef du
service télévision et notamment j'avais
envoyé une de mes journalistes voilà qui
travaillait pour d'autres services en
reportage à l'étranger je veux pas te
dire trop d'informations je suis pas sûr
qu'elle qu'elle veuille que ça se sache
et elle faisait un reportage est envoyé
par tf1 il y avait pda qui couvrait
l'évènement ça gros événement
international et elle m'a raconté que le
soir un dîner de gala le soir c'est à
new york et il avait été visiblement
ppda charmé par la journaliste que
j'avais envoyé là bas elle m'a dit
qu'après le soir l'autel denrées dans le
même hôtel et toute la nuit il sonnait
au téléphone à sa chambre une fois qu'il
aggrave crochet qui avait sonné elle
voyait sais pas derrière la porte il
toque à la porte tous temps il remontait
hirsonnais elle dit à la fin j'étais
obligée de mettre un oreiller pour plus
automne le téléphone et les délits
paquito qu'à la porte et le matin elle
est sortie elle est sortie de
l'ascenseur pour le petit déjeuner il
était devant elle il attendait il a dit
mais qu'est ce qui se passe pourquoi tu
ne m'as pas ouvert pour être tape à a
répondu comme si c'était naturel comme
si c'était logique de répondre aux
sollicitations de ppda et les mouches ou
les régimes tête et fait charmante sans
le vouloir mais ça ne méritait pas qui
est toute la nuit il me sonne aïta pas
ma porte comme ça donc quand il ya une
pression pression qui peut être mise
sans que ça soit forcément il alors tu
vois un service à ce moment là est ce
que tu a reproché ce comportement n'y a
pas eu d'actes ya peu 8 ac n'a pas voulu
elle elle même n'a pas voulu donner
suite à sa
base elle pensait que c'était ya une
vingtaine d'années mais elle n'a pas
voulu donner suite à ça elle me la
raconter parce que c'est elle s'est
livrée mais la palme du match de suite
voilà non ce que je voudrais dire dans
cette histoire c'est que dans les faits
m en vrai on sait très bien que ça va
nulle part puisque vous dites il faut
une preuve elle a beau loupé n'allait
pas donner de l'argent comment est-ce
qu'elle va prouver dans une pièce à deux
qui a eu pénétration qui a eu viol
aujourd'hui c'est donc une parole contre
une autre il ya plus des caps add n'ya
que comment elle va prouver ça dans les
faits aujourd'hui ça va nulle part
d'une collaboration d'éléments maillage
bien 10 on appelle ça des indices graves
et concordants qui laisse penser que et
donc le juge peut avoir son intime
conviction intime conviction que à la
fois ce que dit la plaignante ce qu'on
dit d'autres personnes les personnes qui
ont été entendues la confrontation qui
peut être fait elle peut estimer à tort
peut-être elle peut estimer qu' il y a
eu en ce qui la concerne elle renverra
pour viol mais ça veut pas dire que le
tribunal et c'est là où je vous suis
tribunal qui sera saisie en chef à la
cour d'assises serviolles la con
d'assises qui est saisie va retenir le
viol parce que là encore c'est un c'est
une nouvelle affaire concours est à
suivre devant la cour d'assises donc on
n'est pas prêt terminé malheureusement
assez d'accord il est pas mère et son
adversaire roland mêmes ppda et est en
droit de se porter plainte pour
diffamation à l'heure actuelle